per questi ragazzi è benvenuta questo
nuovo io sono tra dj oggi sono in umido
un po particolare è da un po che gioca
la vonn gas non adesso registrato un
sacco di altre partite spettacolari che
sia lingue figliole questa partita che
state queste partite che state per
vedere lo registrate le primissime volte
che ho giocato da mondiale prile la
prima volta aveva acceso un altro po
volevo far vedere un pochettino come era
all'inizio fa ridere come cosa perché
quando non sei giocare all'inizio è ma è
molto divertente niente buona visione
[Musica]
vale ai ragazzi bella bella partita di
nuovo io che noia meno male che sono con
che noia perché che noi a sa giocare
bene e quindi importante che ci sia che
noi adesso mi hanno visto andare con con
leo quindi non sto vicino non ammazzo
leo neanche cesca che sta facendo ste
cose
aspetto che che noi a faccia la prima
mossa proviamo ad andare a sorveglianza
ragazzi da 11 a sorveglianza perché
qualcuno sta guardando le camere penso
sia che noia a noi nichi ok e nicky
vociare
tusk allora non so chi ammazzare perché
se dietro arriva qualcuno scappa
speriamo che non passino i chili sono un
problema torniamo indietro raga vediamo
chi chi chi beh non posso votare le
actor ok dove due allora miliari di tpl
fra ci odiano
io mi fido abbastanza diste me ho fatto
io sto facendo la meritata ragazze
fatemeh di olio scrivo questo è quella
delle provette che non capivo come
funzionasse come si diceva di aspettare
ma vai a fare qualcos'altro
io ti ho votato c'è una fanatica di
premiarli carli è perché erano operativi
la sua no scusami
io mi fa schifo schifo io dai io lo vedo
bene viste a ok
ricordiamoci la votato comunque sospetto
su qualcuno ce l'ha perché non è morta
ma l'edizione potevano vota passava che
lo votasse ancora uno che noi è stato ha
quindi non stiamo anche noi avrebbe
tanto siamo noi i killer dobbiamo
ammazzare c'è step che l'unico che ha
sospetti un maledetto leo mi sta
attaccato perché vuole veramente
rompermi le palle
quindi facciamo il coso qua però
attenzione che se ci sono le telecamere
devi far fuori leo le ho vista veramente
appiccicato ragazzi quindi o andiamo a
fare le robe in admin leo mista
appiccicato quindi io stare in admin un
attimo a vedere
a far finta di feder e non è in realtà
non me ne frega nulla
io sto un po qua perché voglio che
voglio destare pochi sospetti controllo
la gente che mi ha visto allora dov'è
allora io stavo guardando le telecamere
tolgo la schermata delle telecamere e
vetusta è morto aspetta vero intel è
capito come funziona e cosa no io no io
io sono entrata c'erano step non è
possibile non c'era nient'altro perché
c'ero anch'io
no se nome lorenzo non vedere le camere
e stavo guardando telecamere se ce l'ho
anch'io le telecamere sono entrata ho
visto che sia entrato tuo ho detto vabbè
me ne vado
non sapevo allora io ho visto che non è
riuscito a me peso
il problema che la bozza di bad bees
telecamera collegata quindi più lui
siete scannando quello che potrebbe
essere che non gli occhi del
collegamento nel senso che avevo accusa
però io sono entrata e uscita angolare
tue le telecamere visto che sono entrate
uscite ad ahmed bay io da telecamere non
ho visto un cambio ti giuro io poi ero
solo charlie che passava pietro che è ma
dico in alto tipo c'è il corridoio che
porta dentro l'infermeria
se mi hai visto entrare uscire vuol dire
che c'è solo per sempre dalla botola
sinceramente non me ne sono accorto 10
secondi per bene per diana annunciarle
che non ha secondo me non serve per
forza charlie non ne abbiamo perso
vasco che te la devi smettere di essere
sempre imposto ma mi spiegate che cosa
migliore è che stavolta io lo sapevo che
in quell'altro ma basta il posto
madonna va bene io e leo che qua ci
divertiamo ai ragazzi secondo me io e
leo potremo divertirci perché la prima
volta che lo faccio con leo e secondo me
potrebbe essere interessante lui mi
segue perché non sa dove è passato
subito che noi ha però ben è stato un
pazzo perché è stato paese è stato ho
capito perchè l'ha fatto perché la vuole
eliminare subito perché la più brava il
problema qual è il problema è che la
fattura secondo me mi date le telecamere
lo stavo andando a riportarlo pena che
mi sono mutato mi sono mutato per
portato in questa volta a leo ha avuto
un culo così ma eliminato la persona che
doveva eliminare perché che noi è la più
forte quindi culo bytecode ipad ios ti
possa fare ce la siamo giocata bene
perché nessuno ci si aspetta ancora
quindi bravo leo che ha tolto che bravo
e leo che ha tolto che noia bravissimo
nichi deve morire adesso però non lo
ammazzerò mista attaccato tutto il tempo
ora che ha maledetto in panne e nicky mi
sta seguendo veramente tantissimo quindi
posso usarlo come alibi per il fatto che
mi ha seguito tanti per bra leo ha
capito veramente come sia per i ragazzi
e perché lei adesso inizia e o non ha
mai giocato ad amon gas primavera ha
capito esattamente come si fa sta roba
ok c'è pietro che tira al cosa posso
no devo sei pazzo ok va bene è giusto è
giusto micheli no maledetto nichi
maledetto nichi praga non dire stronzate
bros e siete entrati due leo e poi avete
chiamato il cadavere era inglese
arrivavo precario fresca allora cesca
entrata esattamente con me stesso
secondo vorrei porgere al minuto 9
errori e le faccio dire cosa secondo lui
mai detto che adesso
e allora io nichi però l'ho visto che
arrivava dalla mia stessa direzione
ho visto nichi cesca per scendere andare
in andare ea e io sono mega convinta
però era cesca arrivata da sopra io sono
entrato per riportare io lo riporti vola
riportato certo che i periodi a 100
report e nello stesso momento
lo giuro no secondo me ne stavo entrando
con i sandali ho visto voi due
e poi tu appena nei lista signorato
indietro appare report sono sicura che
lì dentro appena sono entrato miei visto
tu la7 andati indietro e fattore porto e
meghni che circa un ora ve lo giuro
fermi ma io venivo io dico da è scattata
esattamente come nove racconti giusta io
io non ti ho votato solo perché ti hanno
ammazzato tutti ok per quello non ti
volevo votare però secondo me non sa
ghani chi no perché veniva venivano alla
cabrio mini io sono stato tutto il tempo
con la di appena lo si ottiene stanno
attenti adesso pietro non è un pizza
formazioni dovremmo stare vicini io e
leo e far fuori due insieme
fare se leo capisce sta roba emergency
meeting di pietro ok perché ai ragazzi
perché la cosa semplice se gli impostori
fanno uccisioni ho perso io dico adesso
io ho detto rimesso che là dentro niente
lo so devo tanto ma l'avvocato leo
facciamole pichichi fermati se tu
davvero non lo sei
se davvero non lo so ma allora se non è
che le cose
ok alla rinaldo raga meeting subito è la
di ok
e se mi ammazza e perché se mi ammazzate
quindi vedremo se diamo alziamo vedremo
come v1 non posso farlo va bene falda e
devo aspettare la seconda
io dico a pietro che l'unico che
ovviamente non c'era in mezzo basati su
quello che dicono il genere che ognuno
dice quello che vuole
poi vedrete fai fai fai da te
l'udeur infatti la che lavora allora a
prescindere ma lo vedi ma lo vedi chi mi
ha votato valore di le avete votato me
lo stesso e risse chi moretti quando
siamo arrivati difende rilievo sotto
esame racca finalmente maledetto
vorrebbe subito
adesso ma lo faccio tifoso
bravi bravi ci sta ci sta ci sta ragazzi
che sono i primi a volte savon grazie è
stato comunque po come quando guardo i
miei primi video this lander me adesso
di famiglia mi spaventava i tempi che
adesso è uguale e quindi spero che ci
sia piaciuto
lasciatemi piace e che è un commentino
qua sotto domani esce pro forma
tra due giorni e uscirà appunto il
proseguito di among us che sarà cioè non
ve lo dico perché sarà incredibile va
beh ma lo vedrete voi da ragazzi
[Musica]